so the problem with joe jorgensen is
that when you're so out of touch
with what's going on in the culture
right now and you just say something
like this that rightly by you is
perceived as caving in to a literal mob
in this time period while joe jorgensen
is tweeting that the american people
have the government has perpetrated one
of the greatest crimes against the
american people in modern american
history which were the lockdowns kicking
tens of millions of people out of work
with no legal justification just under
emergency powers govern governor decrees
we're many dictators now it's illegal
now for you to go to work and at the
same time they have raped the american
people just completely looted the
treasury and bailed out every giant
corporation in the country it was like
the the most heinous crime committed
against the american people and in that
moment to stand up and say you know what
the problem is you average american
you're not anti-racist enough
that's the real issue that's what
libertarians have to
say your business didn't it